[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم
وهذه العربي
في قطع الرباط
سبونج بوب
طالت حتى النائبه العامه والاخير يتحداه
يدكم مكفوفه
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
ازمه دواء تضرب شرقا وغربا اوروبا من دون
مضادات حيويه وبوتن يفتح تحقيقا في فراغ
الصيدليات
[موسيقى]
من تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا والتي تزداد
التقارير يوما بعد يوم عن انها تنتظر
تحولا جوهريا نحن نشير الى الخبر العاجل
الذي ورد قبل قليل عن انفانتجون يقول انه
تزويد الدبابات دبابات ابرونز الامريكيه
همم القتاليه الى اوكرانيا سيشمل الدعم
الفني والتدريب ولكن سي ان ماذا نقلت قبل
ذلك ان الرئيس همم الروسيبل لازم يربتون
سيتخذ خطوه كبيره خلال الاسابيع القادمه
لاستعاده زمام المبادره في الحرب مع
اوكرانيا
واضافت سي ان ان انه يخطط لتعبئه جديده قد
تصل الى 200,000 جندي لزياده زخم قواته
خاصه في معارك دومباز المسؤولون افاد بان
واشنطن نصحت الرئيس الاوكراني بالترك
يز عارك الجنوب بدلا من بخموط لي ضعف
اهميتها الاستراتيجيه الا انه رفض
في الاثناء نقلت صحيفه جورنال عن مسؤولين
امريكيين قولهم ان الولايات المتحده تتجه
الى ارسال دبابات ابرامز الى اوكرانيا
لان الاعلان عن ارسال دبابات ابرمز الى
اوكرانيا سيكون هذا الاسبوع هذا الاعلان
ياتي رغم تصريحات امريكيه سابقه تحدثت عن
مشاكل قد تواجهها اوكرانيا بالتعامل مع
هذه الدبابات بالصيانه والتشغيل
لكن في الوقت الذي تتحرك فيه واشنطن
بالسرعه غرقه المانيا في حيرتها تجاه
تزويد كياف بدبابات ليوبار طبعا الموضوع
الان حسن ولكن المؤشرات الايجابيه كانت
تاتي من وكاله الانباء الالمانيه قبل قليل
والتي نقلت عن مصادرها ان المستشاره
الالماني سيوافق على تزويد اكاف بالدبابات
الاخبار العاجله تحدثت قبل قليل عن ان
وفقا لجيشبيجل على الاقل عن ان المانيا
سترسل عشر دبابات دي اوكرانيا ولكن موعد
الوصول غير محدد
ماذا حدث يا طاهر خلال الساعات الماضيه
راغب بهنام مع التفاصيل
داخل هذا المقر مقر المستشاريه الالمانيه
في وسط برلين يدور نقاشا حامل الان لاتخاذ
قرارا حول طلب بولندا السماح لها بارسال
دبابات ليوبارد الى اوكرانيا هذه الدبابات
الالمانيه الصنع لا يمكن لاي دوله اشترتها
من المانيا ان ترسلها من دون اذن من هنا
وفيما تتجه انظاره الحلفاء الغربيين الى
هذا المقر على الاقل في الايام القليله
المقبله يزداد التشابك بين المستشار
ونوابا من الحزبين في الائتلاف الحاكم
ونوابا ايضا من حزب المعارضه الرئيسي
الذين يتخذون مكاتب لهم على موعد امطار
قليله في مقابل مقر المستشاريه في هذا
المبنى دعوات تصدر من هنا تحثه المستشار
على اتخاذ قرار سريع بارسال هذه الدبابات
الى بولندا وتحذير من انه قد يتسبب
بانقسام اوروبا
ثقيل على كاهل المستشار الالماني الذي
يتخوف من ان تتسبب هذه الدبابات بجرب
بلاده الى الحرب حمل ومسؤوليه يقول البعض
تاريخيه امام المانيا والسؤال الذي ينتظر
الجميع ردا عليه الان هل تكون المانيا على
قدر هذا الحمل ام انها ام ستتسبب بالغزلان
مره جديده
بما تطلبه كان معدل فساد العالي في اروقه
الحكومه والمؤسسات الاوكرانيه
المذبح الاداريه طبعا بقياده الرئيس
الاوكراني فولوديميري
فساد متجدرا في مفاصل الدوله في اوكرانيا
ورثته عن حقبه الاتحاد السوفيتي عمقته
الحرب بما تحمله من فوضى تزيد فرص
الاستغلال تقاطع بين الحرب والفساد فقام
الازمه الاوكرانيه خاصه في المؤسسات
العسكريه
اقالات واستقالات طالت عددا من المسؤولين
الاخران على خلفيه فضائح فساد
مبالغ فيها شراء منتجات غذائيه للعسكريين
في مكاتب وزاره الدفاع ليست حاله فرديه
المخاوف من شبهات تصل الى نطاق واسع خاصه
في المؤسسه العسكريه لتطرح احتماليه
التحول اوكرانيا الى السوق لتهريب الاسلحه
تلك الاسلحه التي يقدمها الغرب في اطار
المساعدات العسكريه
حمله نجمت عن وعود اطلقها الرئيس لنسكي
منذ ثلاث سنوات يبدو انها تؤتي ثمارها
الان
واتعاهد باتخاذ قرارات رئيسيه بشان القضاء
عليه هذا الاسبوع
خاطئه وان الرقابه في الوزاره تتم على
العقود المبرمه
الدفاع اثناء فتره الحرب الاستثنائيه
جهود انكب عليها جنسكي للرد على مخاوف
الغرب من سويس استخدام الاسلحه التي ترسل
لاوكرانيا لاستمرار مواجهه روسيا
الفساد هو عامل الثقه الذي سيجذب الحلفاء
الغربيين للاستمرار بتقديم المساعدات
العسكريه واعاده اعمار اوكرانيا التي تلقى
الضربه قاسيه في بنيتها التحتيه خلال اقل
من عام بل هو اكبر من ذلك على المدى
الطويل عضويه الاتحاد الاوروبي مظله امان
تطالب بها اوكرانيا لحمايتها من زحف
البيدق الروس الى عمر العربيه
ومعنى من الكويت
اهلا بك معنا يا استاذ سيده لماذا تاخرت
الحرب على الفساد لماذا يجب ان تخاض هذه
الحرب في اتون الحرب المستعره في الميدان
بعد الغزو او بعد التدخل الروسي في
اوكرانيا
موجوده في كل العالم وفي اوكرانيا كذلك
لكن في نفس الوقت تسجيل وتضحيه المسؤولين
ومقاداتهم
الى مكافحه الفساد وليس ان تعمل
والفساد خاصه كما ذكرتهم في ظروف الحرب
فهذا الفساد يمكن ان تساوي
الذي يضر لمصالح ليس ايه يعني كان وزاره
واحده ولكن اوكرانيا بشكل عام وطبعا نحن
همم شعبا وكذلك حكومه ورئيسا نحن ندعم
الشفافيه في
المحاكمه هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين تم توجيهه
اليهم تهمه الفساد
في نفس الوقت سيكون ضمانا الاخرين حتى
يخاف من
كل هذه الاعمال تحتها همم المراقبه خاصه
في همم
فيجب ان نذكر هنا ان هذه التضحيه الكبيره
للمسؤولين همم بما فيها على مستوى المناطق
ولا مستوى الوزراء همم وعلى مستوى حتى
لمكتب الرئاسي ليس جميع هذه الحركه مرتبطه
بالفصاده نحن سمعنا منذ سبتمبر الماضي
الاعلانات حول توقعات في تغيير بعض
الوزراء او النائب الوزراء ولكن
ما يحقق الان وهنا كذلك تزامنا
الفساد وفي نفس الوقت الحركه العاديه يعني
ان تكون فضيحه الفساد تحديدا بوزاره
الدفاع
الاوكرانيه وان تاتي بعد قمه رمش تايم كيف
سيؤثر ذلك على الدعم الغربي همم من حيث
السلاح من حيث المال لكم وهو المتشكك اصلا
بحجم هذا الدعم وكيف سيؤثر ذلك ايضا على
معنويات الجيش الاوكراني على الارض
في الحقيقه هذا هذه القضيه
ففعلا هي تؤثر كشف الفساد كظاهره التي
موجوده
تؤثر بصوره سلبيه على
السمعه اوكرانيا لكن هذا يؤكد على نحن على
ان انا
معتزمين بالمكافحه الفساد واعتقد ان
كذلك المساعدات التي تصل الى اوكرانيا
خاصه العسكريه منها وخاصه
للاستعمال في وزاره الدفاع فمن ناحيته
الشعب نحن نصند همم
القرارات التي سيتم محاكمه هؤلاء الاشخاص
المفسدين نحن لا همم نخفي الحقيقه
والمحكمه في اوكرانيا سيتم طبقا للقانون
الاوكراني نحن دوله القانون المحكمه هي
شفافه وكل قرار هو مفتوح صحفيين والمحللين
ولكن ربما يجب ان يشمل شخصيات اخرى
التحقيق على الاقل مع شخصيات اخرى غير
المحاكمات للاشخاص الذين يشبه بهم او هناك
ادله ضدهم اليس كذلك وهل الوقت متاح هل
رئيس قادر همم على ان يستغني عن كل هذه
القيادات في هذه المواقع المهمه والحساسه
في ظل هذه الحرب نعود ونذكر
نعم اكيد هذا مهم لانه التحقيق مع شخص
واحد قد يفضح
تراء ارتباط مسؤولين اخرين وكذلك حتى لو
نائب الوزير الدفاع حتى لو لم يكون مرتبط
ولن يتم توجيه اليه تهمه الفساد
حتى لو لم يكن مرتبط فساد اصلا فهو تنحى
كذلك من منصبه اليوم او في الغد او في
الامس بسبب لانه مسؤول مباشر على همم
توظيف هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين قاموا بهذا
الفساد اذا همم طبعا همم الوقت غير متاح
لدينا نحن يجب اتخاذ القرارات سريعا
والحركه التغييرات قد يعطينا فرصه اكبر
ليه مكافحه الغزو الروسي همم
مره اخرى اريد ان اؤكد ان تشجينه الفاسدين
الى مكافحه الفساد وتنظيف الصف المسؤولين
في اوكرانيا ما قد يؤثر بشكل يعني يجب
تحليل بشكل مفتوح هذه الوديه في اوكرانيا
واعتقد ان المساعدات العسكريه
والانسانيه لاوكرانيا لن تتوقف لان نحن
نقوم بتنظيفنا وهو ما نسال عنه الان همم
انا وراويه بخصوص الدعم بالدبابات
الالمانيه هناك عدد من الدول بعد ما وافقت
المانيا همم على ذلك ابدت استعدادها لكي
تزود اوكرانيا
ليوبارد الان ما هو الموقف لانه سمعنا
الكثير من الطلبات الملحم همم
ويعني لكن نريد ان نسمع الموقف الان منكم
بعد الاعلان عن الارسال ولكن عدد قليل
فعلا هناك بعد التسريبات وكذلك لتصريحات
رسميه لا يمكن ان الان ان نقيم عدد حقيقي
عدد الدبابات التي سيتم ارسالها الى
اوكرانيا ولكن اعتقد ان الارجيحيه تاتي
لتزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات متقدمه ونتوقع
علاوه الى الدبابات متوقع كذلك تزيد
بالطائرات لانه هذه الاسلحه المتقدمه
سيصائد في انهاء هذه الحرب في اقرب وقت
ممكن عن طريق اخراج القوات الروسيه من
كامله الاراضي الاوكرانيه بما فيها الخير
واعتقد فعلا هذه الاخبار ايجابيه بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا وهذا كذلك له وصل هذه
الانتدابات عندما كانت واضحه ان اوكرانيا
ستصمد امام الغزو الروسي لو كان ازاله لو
كان الدماء الاوكراني قال ايه موجود في
صحه المعركه
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من الكويت ايفانسيدا
ادبلوماسي قال الاوكراني
يبدو ان روسيا حصلت جزئيا على ما تريد
الحديث هنا عن بث الفرقه في حلف الناتو
موسكو قالتها اكثر من مره صراحه بان الحرب
في اوكرانيا هي حرب بينها وبين الحلف لا
شك في ذلك فحلف شمال الاطلسي هو العدو
التاريخيه اللدود لموسكو التي لا تتردد في
التمديد بحركاته التوسعيه فانضمامه اي عضو
جديد للحلف يشكلها مؤرقا بالنسبه لروسيا
اخر راغبين في الانضمام الى الحلف هم
السويد وفنلندا التاني رفع بوجه بوجهيه ما
اردوغان الفيتو التركي فما فشله في تحقيقه
بوتن ربما ينجح فيه اردوغان الذي تحول الى
حجر عثره حقيقي يحول دون انضمام الدولتين
او احداهما على الاقل حتى الان الى الحلف
الاكثر من ذلك فان التعنت التركي بدا في
تشتيت مجهودات البلدين الى درجه الانقسام
هل سينكي بدات بالتفكير فعليا في السعي
الى الانضمام للحلف بشكل فردي الاعلان جاء
على لسان وزير الخارجيه الفنلندي بك
هافيستو الذي قال ان على بلاده التفكيره
في الانضمام في الانضمام الى الحلف بشكل
مستقل عن السويد
تصريحات تعكس اقتناعا ضنيا لدفندا بان
حظوظها اقوى من السويد لا سيما بعد
استبعاد الرئيس التركي دعم طلب السويد
بسبب عدم امتثالها لطلباته وتنامي المشاعر
المعاديه للمسلمين فيها حتى ولو اعلنت
سويد انها تريد استمرارا الحوار مع تركيا
علمه ان معارضه تركيه نابعه بالاساس من
مطالبها بخصوص تسليم السويد عناصر من حزب
العمال الكردستاني الذي تصنفه انقره جماعه
ارهابيه وعرضه عكس السويد فان فنلندا لا
تواجه ممانعه تركيه كبيره وهو ما اكدته
رئيسه الوزراء الفنلنديه سنمارين حين قالت
انه لا توجد مشكله كبيره لتركيا مع فنلندا
وربما تتعلق المشكلات بالسويس بعيدا عن
ملف الانضمام المنفرد لفنلندا فان الموضوع
بشكل عام مرتبط بشكل اساسي بقرار انقره
الذي سيتاجل على الارجح الى ما بعد اجراء
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه والتي من
المفترض ان تجرى في شهر مايو المقبل ما
يعني ان على هالكسين
الانتظار لاشهر الاخرى حتى تتفرغ انقره
لموضوعهما طبعا هذا نوع من الانقسام
المعلن بين انهيته لكنه هناك انقساما اعمق
راويه ربما يتعلق بامور اخطر وهي السلاح
وليس فقط بالعضويات صحيح طاهر الانقسامات
تحوم بالحلف من الخارج وايضا من الداخل
حيث ان الخلاف اشتد بين اعضائه حول تسليم
اوكرانيا اسلحه ثقيله قبل ان تاتي
الانفراجه مع الانباء عن موافقه المستشار
الالماني على تزويدك بالدبابات وسوا وافق
شغل او لا فان بوتن تلقف هذا التوجه
الغربي بغضب كبير من خلال تنديده بسعينات
المستمر الى زياده امدادتها بالاسلحه
غضبوا موسكو شمالا الامدادات الامريكيه
ايضا حيث حذر نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي
ساريا كاف من خطورته وما يمكن ان تسببه من
عواقب وخيمه اذا هي مواقف لا تزيد الوضع
الا توترا وقد يسير بالحرب نحو سيناريو
جديد اكثر حده وهو ما اسماته موسكو بالحرب
الكبيره التعبير رجاء على لسان مارجريتا
سيمونيان وهي واحده من اشهر مقدمي البرامج
في التلفزيون الحكومي حيث توقعت ان تبدا
هذه الحرب بحلول نهايه الشتاء بعد
الانذارات الاخيره للرئيس الروسي
ستكون هناك حرب كبيره بالتاكيد قبل نهايه
فصل الشتاء سيحدث شيء كبير والا ما كانت
لتصدر هذه التحذيرات
السؤال المطروح الان ما هي التحذيرات التي
ارسلها بوتن ولم تلتفت اليها اوكرانيا
وحلفاء يبدو ان امدادات الاسلحه الغربيه
اشعلت نيران غضب روسيا التي لم تعد تستثير
السخاء الغربي مع اوكرانيا فبينما يسعى
الحلف الاطلسي الى امدادك في الدبابات
تتعد تتعهد واشنطن بمواصله اغلاق اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه وما اثار حفيظه روسيا بشكل اكبر
هو الضغوط التي يمارسها حلف الناتو على
واشنطن من اجل ارسال نظام الصواريخ
الامريكي التايتنز وهو صاروخ بعيد المدى
يبلغ مداه 200 وهو ما يرفضه البيت الابيض
حتى الان خوفا من التصعيد كما ان روسيا
تبدو منزعجه جدا من الاسلحه الامريكيه
التي تصل كاف وبخاصه راجمه الصواريخ هذه
مارس التي الحقت الكثير من الاضرار في
صفوف القوات الروسيه
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون معنا في العربيه 360 ايضا صفقه
مروحيات الهجوميه في الطريق من روسيا
لايران والغرضوا
تحفيف على
التقدير
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اكد وزير الخارجيه
الروسيه بروف ان بلاده تعول على ان تاخذ
دول الاتحاد الافريقي في الاعتبار الوضع
الحقيقي في اوكرانيا عند حوارها مع الغرب
بشان هذا الملف
الذي يقوم بجوله افريقيه الى
ان كان الغرب يعدها منذ فتره طويله ضد
روسيا وكان يجهز اوكرانيا
اذا هذا وجه اخر للحرب الاوكرانيه او
انشئنا الدقه هو عارض جانبي وساحته
افريقيا لكن المواجهه هنا ليست عسكريه
وانما استراتيجيه تتعلق بالنفوذ وتحديدا
في القاره السمراء فما يحدث من تقلبات في
نفوذ القوى العظمى داخل هذه القاره يؤكد
بان يوضعا جديدا من التحالفات يتم نسجه
روسيا التي تعيش صراع عن حقيقيا مع القوى
الغربيه بسبب عمليتها العسكريه في
اوكرانيا وجهت البوصله بشكل واضح لو نحو
الدول الافريقيه بحثا عن خلفاء جدد
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه في التغلغل في
افريقيا بدات عام 2020 عندما لجا رئيس
افريقيا الوسطى همم فلسطين
الى موسكو من اجل دعمه للبقاء في الحكم
التجربه الروسيه تكررت في مالي عقب انقلاب
الكونونال السيميتا في 2020 الذي تم
بمسانده روسيه دون ان نانسي انضمام
بوركينا فاسو الى دائره نفوذ الروسي مؤخرا
بعد دعم موسكو الانقلاب الذي انتهى بتعيين
ابراهيم تروري رئيسا للمجلس العسكري في
اخر خطوه روسيا لمد الجسور مع القاره
السمراء الجوله الافريقيه لوزير الخارجيه
الروسي سرجيا لافراف التي استهلها من جنوب
افريقيا علما انها الجوله الافريقيه
الثانيه للافراف في اقل منها زيارات
لافراف ليبريتوريا حملت عنوان عريضه
باهتمام كبير وهو الاعلان عن تدريبات
عسكريه مشتركه بين روسيا والصين وجنوب
افريقيا ستقام على الساحل الشرقي لجنوب
افريقيا في وقت لاحق من شهر فبراير المقبل
هي تدريبات التي دافعت عنها وزيره خارجيه
جنوب افريقيا
بالقول ان استضافه مثل هذه التدريبات مع
الاصدقاء تمثل المسار الطبيعيه لهذا
العلاقه
انسى ان النفوذ العسكريه الروسي في
افريقيا توسع من خلال قوات
ڤاجنر التي بات تنتشر في الكثير من
البلدان علما بان هذا التوسع لفاكنر جاء
بعد انحسار تواجد القوات الاجنبيه الاخرى
وفي مقدمتها القوات الفرنسيه التي تستعد
لمغادره بوركينا فاسو بطلب من الاخير هو
انسحاب في سلسله من الانسحابات الفرنسيه
من القاره كانت حلقتها السابقه من مال
المجاوره اذا هذا ما تفعله روسيا في
القاره الافريقيه لكن ماذا عن الخطط
الصينيه التي هي حلف كبير ومهم لروسيا همم
وكيف عن اسومها الخاص
طيب سنتابع همم بالقول بانه بدون ادنى شك
هي تحركات مشابهه ثم التودد الى افريقيا
اصابت الصين ايضا
ليس وليد اليوم وانما يعود لسنوات طويله
مضت وهو ما تعكسه معطيات عده اخره زياره
وزير الخارجيه الصينيه الجديد تشينج جانغ
لعده دول افريقيه في اوائل مهامه وهو
تقليد صني معتاد منذ ثلاثه عقود ويظهر
الاهميه الكبيره التي تليها بكين لافريقيا
عسكريا ايضا فان الصين تملك قاعدتها
العسكريه الوحيده في الخارج تحديدا في
دوله جيبوتي الواقعه في شرق افريقيا وذلك
منذ العام 2017 كما ان العديد من وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه اشارت الى وجود مشروع
صينيه لاقامه قاعده عسكريه في غرب افريقيا
وتحديدا في غينيا الاستوائيه الواقعه على
ساحل المحيط الاطلسي اما تجاريا فحدث ولا
حرج الصين هي اكبر شريك تجاريه للقاره
الافريقيه بحيث يبلغ حجم تبادل تجاري بلغ
في العام الماضي على الاقل 2004 254 مليار
دولار ومن دون شك فان التقارب الصينيه
الروسيه الافريقي لا يروق كثيرا للولايات
المتحده التي بدات تتحرك لمواجهه هذا
التغلغل واشنطن بادرت بارسال وزيره
الخزانه الامريكيه جانيت يلن في جوله
افريقيه لاعاده احياء علاقاتها مع افريقيا
التي شهدت نوعا من الفطور في السنوات
القليله الماضيه تاتي زياره بعد سته اشهر
من اعلان الولايات المتحده عن استراتيجيه
جديده تهدف الى التدارك سنوات من الاهمال
لقاره افريقيا علما انا واشنطن استضافت
قمه افريقيه الشهر الماضي الرغبه في
مواجهه تغلغل الروسيه والصيني في القاره
بدجليا في تصريحات وزيره الخزانه
الامريكيه التي القت باللوم على روسيا في
تفاقم المشاكل الاقتصاديه لافريقيا كما
وجهت انتقادا منفصلا للصين بسبب ممارستها
الاقراضيه
ويبقى السؤال هل تاخرت واشنطن يشير الى
الخبر العاجل عن البيت الابيض ردا على
للعربيه حول الخلاف الامريكي الالماني
تحالف دعم اوكرانيا صامد
[موسيقى]
اشار معهد دراسات الحرب والذي يقع مقره في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى ان موسكو
وطهران تدرسان امكانيه توفير مروحيات
هجوميه لايران وان هذه الصفقه سيكون لها
دور في تخفيف ضغط العقوبات الامريكيه على
الطرفين اذا روسيا تزود ايران ذلك
الصفقه ورد في تقرير لوكاله تسنيم بعد
زياره رئيس مجلس النمو الروسي لطهران
الاثنين الماضيه نشير ايضا الى هذا العجل
عن البيت الابيض الامر متروك لكل دوله
لتقرر حجم المساعده العسكريه
فرضت عقوبات على ثلاثه اشخاص من حزب الله
لاتهامهم بتسهيل تحويل الاموال الحسبه
واوضحت الوزاره اوضحت ان المعاقبين سهل
وتمويل ميليشيات حزب الله عبر مراكز
الصرافه
حجر ثقيل القاه قاضي التحقيق طارق البيطار
في المياه الراكده لقضيه انفجار مرفق
بيروت البيطار اماره باستدعاء عدد كبير من
المسؤولين وبينهم مدعي عام التمييز غسان
عويدات ليرد عليه الاخير بانه بان يديه
مكفوفه
بين من ايد قرارات البيطار الجريئه ومن
وصفه بالمريض
[موسيقى]
هو القاضي الذي كفر يده اكثر من 40 مره
عاد بعد غياب تخطى العام اشهر انتفاضته
القضائيه بوجه محاولات جماعيه لعرقلتي سير
العداله
وبعد ان اجاز المحقق العدلي طارق البيطار
لنفسه استئناف التحقيقات انفجار
رفض المدعي العام التمييزي غسان عويدات
قرار استدعائه رسميا ضمن رائحه من ثمانيه
اشخاص على راسها ايضا المدير العام للامن
العام اللواء عباس ابراهيم الذي بني على
البيطار من استدعائه سابقا
قرار اثلج قلوب اهالي الضحايا بعد ان بحث
حناجرهم مطالبين باستئنا في التحقيقات
راي قانوني مخالف ممكن مراجعه المحاكم
المختصه مثل ما حتى هو باراره اشار لهذا
الموضوع انه اليوم المجلس العدلي عنده
الصلاحيه في ابطال او باعتبار ايا تحقيقات
غير بموقع ما لنا بموقع اما المساله
الثانيه لليوم عم تتحرك اكثر هي موقف
النيابه العامه من مساله خلقت السبيل
بحقوقين بالملف اليوم في خمس اخلاء سبيل
لا يزيل اليوم مصير تنفيذه او عدم تنفيذه
مجهول
على اثرها ازدحمت ارجوك تقصر العدل بحسب
المعلومات بمفيدينا من المده عليهم وعلي
حسن خليل ويوسف
الوزراء المحسوبين على حزب الله وحركتي
امل
ووسطنا خوف النيه وشارعا شبيه بشارع
السابع من ايار ومخاطر قد يتعرض لها
البيطار تحدثت اوساطه قاضي التحقيق عن
قيامه بما يمليه عليه ضميره وان ما يخشى
عليه فقط هو مسار التحقيقات
اسامي كبيره
بالقضاء يتركب الشارع اللبناني ردود فعل
من استدعاهم القضاء في قضيه احداثها بعد
تجميدها لاكثر من عام ووصل مطالبات دوليه
بتحقيقا عادل وشفاف غن ويتيم العربيه
بيروت
وانضم الينا من بيروت جاك الجميل المحامي
وشقيق احد ضحايا انفجار المرفا اهلا بك
استاذ
جاك يعني تصورك لما ستفعله النيابه العامه
التميزيه في لبنان بعد قرار القاضي
البيطار هل ستعامل بايجابيه وستنفذه كقرار
قانوني ام سترفضه مراعاه للطبقه السياسيه
وبعض الاسماء الكبرى الموجوده الان في
السلطه وان رفضته ما يعني تاثير ذلك على
الشارع اللبناني وانت احد ضحايا انفجار
المرفق يعني امضيتهم سنتين ونصف وانتم
بالشارع تطالبون بالحقيقه
مساء الخير
بحييك بحيي ضيوفك انا
خيي المرحوم اسمه جاك انا بيار
بسيطه شكرا
واهلنا وبدهم هنا كمان نسكت ونقول يلا عفا
الله عما مضى ومشينا باعتقد هذا الشيء ملح
بقى صح وملح
التحقيق كان حجته انه التحقيق واقف وليش
موقفه وهلا بس
مهم واحد شو يعمل المهمه
بس
بلاش الوزير
امنيه والاوضات بتلاقي كله نتحركوا وحتى
حركوا الشارع نحن الليل ببيروت وثلاث
ارباع الطرقات مسكره للتربيه على الطرقات
الدوليه عم تحترق وانا في شيء لازم اذكركم
اياه تذكر فيه اللبنانيه كمان وبذكر في
حاله احد المسؤولين الكبار طلع قال قال في
حدا عم بيخيرنا بين الاستقرار وبين
العداله نحنا كشعب لبناني بنقول لهم
كاهالي ضحايا وضحايا
باعتقد مش بس اللي توفوا 237 ضحيه هن
الاربع مليون لبناني ان الضحايا ضحايا هذا
النظام المجرم هذا النظام الفاسي وكان
العداله
في لبنان اذا اراد الشعب ان يحقق اعدادات
همم بس عوده الى السؤال
ماذا يمكن ان يحصل مع الخطوات القانونيه
القادمه
من جديد بعد من توقفات يعني هذا سؤال ايضا
يسال وثانيا
باعتقادك ان تم انه لانه لانه
بمعظمهم ما الخطوه المقبله
قرارات القادمه يعني لا تقبل الطعن ولا
المراجعه بالقانون اللبناني
اول شيء القرارات اللي اخدها سلف وسابقا
بحق وزراء الاجهزه الامنيه ما طبقتها
ومراحت لقطتهم بالعكس رجعوا عملوا نواب
وترشحوا وفاته على البرلموه وصاروا بلجان
الاداره والعدل يعني هيدا شيء غير منطقي
وغير مقبول بحياه الله حيا الله شخص بيفكر
بشكل طبيعي او حي الله حزب عم بيرشح ناس
الا اذا بدهم كرمال هيدي النيابه وراء
حسنه
السؤال انا باكد انه بيغض النظر شو صار او
اذا راح يقضعه للتحقيق
انا بعتقد انه هذه المره القاضي اخر قرار
خاصه القاضي بيطار كثير متحفظ وانا كان
همم شفت الوفد الاوروبي القضائي الاوروبي
اسبوع الماضي
وسالوه عن حقيقي ما جاوبوني هن قالوا لي
ما جاوبنا عن شيء عن التحقيق عن ملف يعني
وسالوه عن الاربع الاشخاص اللي بيحملوا
الجنسيه الفرنسيه وهن ضحايا ولكن
هل فعلا متجاوب معهم يعني القاضي بيطار
الاكيد انه
الى صفه الدعم الشعب الشعب طبعا الناس
النزيهه الغير محذبه ولكن الا يمتلك دعما
اوروبيا وامريكا لانه بتصريحات الرسميه
انه يريدون الحقيقه ايضا
بدي اقول لك شغله مدام ما في عنده القاضي
بيطار ما في عنده الا ضميره بيتكل عليه لا
دعم امريكي ولا دعم اوروبي لان لو بده يجي
يتغطى بالدعم الامريكي ما بدنا ننسى له
اسبوع الماضي او من اسبوعين السفيره
الامريكيه بلبنان طلبت من القضاء اللبناني
يفلت او يطلق سراح احد مساجين او
الموقوفين بتفجير مرفا بيروت هو محمد
الليف
واصدر قراريت اخلص سبيل وما اخلص بيله لو
بده يرضى خلال السفاره الامريكيه
او للسفارات او للخارج مثل بعض عم بجرب
يسوي كان بينها الداخليه
ضيعت التي استجدت لديه لكي يعيد تحريك هذا
الملف
همم مش معطيات انا ما اني مخاول احكي باسم
القاضي وانا كمان كمحامي ما بسمح لحالي
اتدخل بعمل القضاء وهذا شيء نطلب من
السياسيين الان في فصل للسلطات بلبنان
نطلب من السيسيين الوزراء والنواب ما
يتدخلوا بعمل القضاء وانا هذا الشيء كمان
ما بسمح لحالي اعمله بس انا بقول هال540
صفحه اللي همم القرار اللي فضه 540 صفحه
اذا انا بدي انقلهم من كتاب اكتبهم 540
صفحه وارجع اطبعهن هو اللي بدهن معي كذا
شهد يعني ان احنا بلبنان معودين انه
القاضي باجل الجلسه سبع اشهر
اثنين 15 سنه
وبيهدي ال ال المسار جديد للتحقيق باعتقد
راح يمشي ومثل ما اصدر بالسابق همم
اتهامات او
ادعاء يعني على كل شخص ما اجى بعتقد ده
هيكفي هيك المسار
وبنتمنى وبنتمنى
مذكرات توقيف هذه البوسته وبنتمنى انه
يصبر القرار الظالمه وساعتها بنصير قدام
المجلس العدل وبتثير كل الاوراق الملف
تمام
للكل بساعتها بيشوفوا عاشور ده كذا
وهذا الشيء كثير مهم ل- همم للمدلعين
وللمده عليهم وحتى لاهيل الموقوفين ولا
الموقوفين
اذا سمحتلنا شكرا جزيلا لشركاتك معنا ليلى
فيرج ميل المحامي وشقيق حجه
وتعزينا لكم مجددا
في العربيه 360 ايضا
شواطئ تايلاند من بهجه الاصفر والازرق الى
كابه الاسود
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نقص في اعدادات الدواء
يشهده العالم خاصه المضادات الحيويه
مع انشغال الشركات الدواء بتصنيع اللقاحات
كرونه
بعد ازمه كورونا والحرب الروسيه في
اوكرانيا وتبعتها من ازمه طاقه وتضخم
يواجه العالم تحديا اخر نقص في امدادات
الدواء على مستوى العالم حيث اعترفت
اوروبا اليوم بانها تواجه تحديا كبيرا في
نقص الادويه
هيئه الدواء الاوروبيه طلبت بالعمل على
مواجهه تناقص امدادات المضادات الحيويه
وادويه خفض الحراره والفلسلين
وكالات اوروبيه عده اكدت ان الطلبه
المتزايده على المضادات الحيويه مصدر قلم
كما عزت الاسباب الى الاحداث السياسيه على
مستوى العالم وقضايا سلسله التوريد
العالميه وانشغال الشركات الطبيه بتصنيع
اللقاحات الكروب
الاسباب الجذريه لنقص الادويه معقده
وتتعلق بعوامل كثيره مثل مشاكل الطاقه
الانتاجيه وزيادات غير متوقعه في الطلب
المفوضيه الاوروبيه وضمان الامدادات
وتنظيم عمليات الشراء المشتركه بدات
بتخزين الادويه والزام المصنعين
ليست القاره العجوز الوحيده في مواجهه
النقص بل حتى الولايات المتحده تعاني ايضا
من نقص في المضاد الحيوي وتواجه الصين على
وزن في الادويه في مشافيها ما يهدد
المناطق الريفيه بالتزامن مع الزياد
الاصابات بفيروس كورونا
اما الرئيس الروسي فقد اقر بوجود نقص في
الادويه في بلاده وطالب بالتحقيق والعمل
على توفيرها
ازمه دواء صامته تجتاح العالم وهي مرتبطه
بنقص انتاج الشركات الكبرى في مصانعها في
الدول الاقل كلفه بسبب التضخم والحرب ونقص
المواد التي تدخل في صناعه الدواء
اهلا بك دكتور
فرانسوا يعني ما هي الادويه التي يعني هي
الاكثر نقصا واين باي بلدان
هلا اكثر شيء ناقص هن الانثى بوتيك
والكورتيزون
مش عم نقدر
المضادات الحيويه
الحقيقيه بالنسبه اليكم او في اسباب اخرى
في اسم حرب بعدين
مع العيد
[موسيقى]
بيبي بيبي يبعثون
افريقيا لانه هون الدوله اللي بتدفع على
الدواء هن هلا
بالاسعار والدوله هون الخنساويه ما بدها
تعلي الاسعار طيب شركات شو عم تقول لما
تخاطبوهم بمواضيع هاي الادويه تحديدا انه
هل هي مشكله مؤقت جدا سيتم حلها او انه
ستطول
هن الشبكات
بس التلبيه قويه بس الدوله فرنسيه
هنا بتامين الادويه اليس هنالك رقابه مثلا
وضروره لتامينها للناس وان لا تتحكم شركات
الادويه والمفيات يعني التي تبتغي الربح
بذلك
اكيد هن الشبكات بفضلوا يبعته ويبيعه
بثاني بلد لانه هنا الاسعار
ربما من الحكومه ومن الوزاره لانها يعني
بصراع لنقل او بخلاف مع هذه الشركات وليس
هناك مشكله حقيقيه قد تعم اكثر من اوروبا
كمان في عالم كتير بيشتغل
على افريقيا
[موسيقى]
اكتشف محامي نائب الرئيس السابق حول
اثنتين 10 وثيقه تم تصنيفها على انها سريه
في منزل التنس الاسبوع الماضي
سيستمر مسلسل اكتشاف الوثائق السريه في
منزل كبار المسؤولين وتستمر معه التساؤلات
حول ثغرات الامريكيه في هذا الملف
[موسيقى]
تبدو قضيه الوثائق السريه التي احتفظ بها
الرئيس الحالي جو فايدن والرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب مؤشرا على مشكله حقيقيه
تواجهها اجهزه الدوله الامريكيه مع
الرؤساء الامريكيين
السيناتور الديمقراطيه
كشفها كيف يتم التعامل مع الوثائق المصنفه
الذريه
وانا اقرا ثم يستعيدها ويضعها في الحقيبه
ويغادر
لكن المساله مختلفه مع الرئيس الامريكي من
الممكن ان نرى الرئيس سبايدر وهو يغادر
وبيده اوراق ويذهب الى مقر الاقامه في
المبنى الرئيسي من البيت الابيض او الى
الطائره لا احد يتابع مع الرئيس الامريكي
ما حصل للاوراق المصنفه سريه
ومرقمه ولا احد يسال عنها او يطلب
استعادتها من الرئيس عندما يغادر او عندما
ينتهي من استعمالها هذه واحده من المشاكل
لكن ما حصل مع بيضه ومن قبله ترامب يتراوح
بين الاهمال والاصرار على عدم احترام
الاجراءات الامنيه وحمايه الوثائق السريه
فبعض الوثائق موجود بحوزه بايضا منذ كان
عضو مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي وقبل ان يصبح
نائبا للرئيس العام 2009
نظام المكتبات العامه وعندما يعطى الرئيس
وثيقه وهي عاده تاتي من السي اي اي او
وزاره الدفاع يجب ان تكون مسجله ومرقمه
الحل الاخر المطروح هو تحويل
كسريه الى النظام الالكتروني وبالتالي
يقفل الدخول اليها بمجرد انتهاء الرئيس من
استعمالها وهذا ما حصل في الايجاز الامني
للرئيس في المكتب البيضاوي في الغانم
العربيه
من اي وقت مضى تم اعاده ضبط ساعه يوم
القيامه
علماء الذره بعد ان قام مجلس بتعديل ساعه
القيامه الرمزيه التي تشير مجازا الى
التحديات التي تواجهها البشريه الى 90
ثانيه قبل منتصف الليل او ساعه النهايه
الثانيه اصبحت 90 ثانيه كانت ساعه هذه
ساعه القيامه احدثت ضجه في 2020 عندما تم
ضبطها حينها عند 100 ثانيه
اول مره تنخفض فيها الى ثواني قبل النهايه
بدلا من
مفاوضات الامم المتحده الساميه السابقه
لحقوق الانسان هذا التحديث وحذرت من انه
يدق ناقوس الخطر وان العالم على حافه
الهاويه وان قادته لا يتصرفون بسرعه
بالطبع يعود هذا التحديث الى
التحديلات يشهدها العالم اليوم بسبب حرب
يعني يا احمد
ثانيا يعني من الاخر صوره اليوم في
العربيه 360 من تايلاند فالشواطئ
الفيروزيه التي كانت وجهه لالاف السياح
تستقبل زائرا فقد تسرب يا طاهر النفط من
احد الانابيب تحت المياه لتتحول مهمه
العمال من خدمه السائحين الى تنظيف الشاطئ
معركه
في استقبال السياح حتى تورطت في معركه
ثانيه مع بقاع النفط وقد تكون الثانيه
اكثر دراره من الاولى
فيديو اليوم من الجزائر
الابيض
بهجت يعرفها جيدا سكان البلاد البارده
تكون مضاعفه في الدول التي تندر فيها هذه
الزياره
[موسيقى]
وهكذا نصل الى رائع الجزائر